Here's a graphic that describes one approach to web services.
This one provided by J2EE, which is Oracle's technology for
dealing with new situations. Three remaining components on the left is your
web browser, which is going to be using HTMLs or applet's, or
possibly even application. On the right, is some kind of database services, and
in between is where the beef is, as far as Oracle is concerned. And that's what
holds the business logic. This is the computational segment, that knows
about the particular application computations. And the way that J2EE has it,
there's two parts. One is a web server, and the other is the EJB containers.
EJB is enterprise java beans which is libraries are API within Java.
Standard interactions then apply, and presumably you can build your
applications using this technology, in a way that can deal with some of
the non-functional constraints that these applications have to be constructed.